müde aber glücklich dürfte die eu
kommissionspräsident in sein nach dem
mammutgipfel sie sagt das ist ein
historischer moment für europa gute
namen frau von der leyen guten namen
casinos historisch ist die summe die da
jetzt auf dem tisch liegt historisch ist
die tatsache dass die eu erstmals in der
geschichte in großem stil
gemeinschaftlich schulden macht die wir
dann alle für alle abstottern muss diese
tatsache jedem in deutschland
automatisch gefallen nun das
wiederaufbauprogramm heißt nicht ohne
grund next generation
denn was wir jetzt machen in dieser
tiefen wirtschaftskrise
wir nehmen gemeinsam geld in die hand um
zu investieren damit unsere gesunden
unternehmen die krise überstehen und
damit auch in zukunft die jungen
menschen arbeit haben und eine
perspektive haben und wir koppeln das
mit investitionen in klimaschutz und
digitalisierung das ist der sinn dieses
paketes das ganze bedeutet auch für sie
und ihre kommission enorm mehr macht
jetzt in zukunft den sie müssen darauf
aufpassen wie diese gelder diese
milliardensummen dann verteilt werden in
den einzelnen mitgliedstaaten das
bedeutet aber auch mehr verantwortung
bei der einhaltung bei der überprüfung
ob diese regeln alle eingehalten werden
vor allem bei denen die jetzt schon
sagen wir lassen uns von brüssel nicht
reinreden wie wollen sie da
sicherstellen dass die regeln
tatsächlich eingehalten werden es gibt
eine ganz klare verabredung und dies
auch festgehalten dem gipfeldokument die
mitgliedstaaten kommen mit ihren
nationalen pläne und das ist auch
wichtig sie wissen am besten was vor ort
nötig ist die kommission legt darüber
erstens das thema klimaschutz zweiter
digitalisierung und dann die
länderspezifischen empfehlungen also da
wo reformen sein müssen
das wird gekoppelt mit den investitionen
das geld wird nur ausgezahlt in
meilenstein wenn sie diese meilensteine
erreicht sind das heißt wir haben ganz
klares system das bei in der tat diesen
großen summen auch die modernisierung
und die nachhaltigkeit im vordergrund
stehen muss
frau von der leyen sie werden mir
zustimmen dass bei so viel geld es sehr
wichtig ist dass den jeweiligen
empfänger ländern als eine opposition
gibt die funktion
dass es freie medien gibt eine
zivilgesellschaft die auch gerne mal
gegen die regierenden aufsteht und
natürlich vor allem eine unabhängige
justiz
da sollte es eigentlich eine verknüpfung
geben zwischen dem haushalt dem ganzen
geld das fließt und der frage der
rechtsstaatlichkeit wir rechtsstaatlich
ist tatsächlich der einzelne empfänger
start
die ist jetzt allerdings in der
vergangenen nacht unter die räder
gekommen und musste einer schwammigen
formulierung weichen warum ich sehe das
völlig anders wenn sie sich den
ursprünglichen gipfel textentwurf
anschauen dann war der schwammig und
brachte verschiedene decks textbausteine
zusammen die eigentlich keinen
zusammenhang haben
jetzt hat das dokument klarheit erstens
das bekenntnis zur rechtsstaatlichkeit
zweitens der ganz klarer auftrag dass
das europäische budget das heißt die
finanziellen interessen der union
geschützt werden müssen
und vor diesem hintergrund dann als
drittes den auftrag an die kommission
ein gesetzesvorhaben auf den weg zu
bringen dass wenn diese prinzipien
gebrochen werden dann auch maßnahmen
ergriffen werden das wollte ich und das
steht im dem gipfeldokument drin wenn
das alles so klar ist wo von der leyen
warum hat dann zum beispiel ungarn
sofort zugestimmt und sagt jetzt wir
haben gewonnen
ungarn und alle anderen haben zugestimmt
weil wir sehr klar die karten auf den
tisch gelegt haben
wir wollen dieses gesetzesvorhaben und
es wird jetzt auch kommen
und wenn man dagegen angehen will später
dann haben wir die unabhängige justiz
auf der europäischen ebene hatte immer
gesagt er will gerade keine verknüpfung
zwischen der frage der
rechtsstaatlichkeit und den
milliarden-hilfen jetzt sagt er ich habe
genau das erreicht was ich wollte
schauen sie ins gipfeldokument rhein
dort sehen sie den auftrag der
kommission das gesetzesvorhaben ist
schon im rats verfahren also jeder kann
auch nachprüfen dass dieses dieser
vorschlag der kommission vorliegt den
werden wir weiter verfolgen und
spätestens dann wenn er beschlossen uns
und übungs er muss nur mit
qualifizierter mehrheit beschlossen
werden
das heißt er kann auch sehr stark
durchgehen und angenommen werden dann
werden sie sehen dass dieses instrument
auch zähne
wir hatten jetzt schon hier in der
sendung den chef der größten fraktionen
im europaparlament der hat gesagt die eu
ist kein geldautomat die eu ist vor
allem eine werte union jetzt sagen sie
das wird alles erst eingeleitet wir
überprüfen das wir machen ein neues
gesetzesvorhaben
warum kann man sowas sowas elementares
für europa nämlich die frage werden in
den einzelnen ländern die grundrechte
eingehalten warum kann man so was auf
die lange bank schieben dieses ist eines
der grund themen der europäischen union
und hier haben wir verfahren die
übrigens laufen auch in manchen
mitgliedstaaten wenn wir sehen dass die
justiz der unabhängigkeit gefährdet ist
oder die medienfreiheit gefährdet ist
oder andere schwächen da sind dann sind
die instrumente da die wir brauchen was
wir bisher nicht hatten ist die
verknüpfung mit den europäischen geldern
und das können wir jetzt auf den weg
bringen das war das ziel der diskussion
ich wollte das so und wir haben das ziel
erreicht
es war lang es gab auch viel streit in
den letzten brüssel an echten sie haben
in vielen runden mit dabei gesessen
bei allem wenn man mal alles
zusammennimmt wieviel europäische
solidarität haben sie dabei jedem
einzelnen mitgliedsstaat gespürt dass
alle mitgliedstaaten ihre eigenen
interessen haben ist völlig klar 27 und
einen hut zu bringen ist nicht einfach
aber was unterm strich geblieben ist ist
dann doch der gemeinsame wille es
zusammen zu schaffen weil wir alle
wissen es steht viel mehr auf dem spiel
als nur unser binnenmarkt und das ist
schon wichtig sondern eben auch diese
wertegemeinschaft die einzigartig ist
auf der welt und alleine die tatsache
dass alle fast 100 stunden zusammen
geblieben sind viel viel länger als
geplant
keiner ist aufgestanden hat die tür
geknallt und das weg gegangen dass wir
zusammen uns durchgerungen haben diesen
riesen kompromiss dieses gewaltige paket
auf den weg zu bringen
das zeigt dass der gemeinsame geist
trägt der muss manchmal durch tiefen
hindurch wie diese fünf tage ist dann
auch waren aber zum schluss das ergebnis
das zählt ursula von der leyen ich danke
ihnen nach brüssel gute nacht danke
ihnen